deprived of their cafe terraces for most
of the past 12 months
parisians weren't letting pouring rain
get in the way
of what is hoped to be the beginning of
the end of lockdown restrictions
we had our first customers here at eight
o'clock this morning
so everybody is waiting to be able to go
into the stores do some shopping just
sit and have a coffee which we love
doing in paris
sitting down at a table on a terrace
watch the world go by
get up going to a store all of that
people are willing to
go to museums indoor venues like the
louvre
can operate at reduced capacity it was
sold out today
early visitors were keen to resume a
modern tourism ritual
before the pandemic france was the
world's most visited country tourism
contributed 7.5 per cent of gdp
to encourage tourists back france will
become one of the few
to offer free covid tests to visitors
tourism
is a key part of the french academy and
that's why we have decided
to have this test for free for the
foreign tourists so that france will be
one of the most
attractive destination among european
countries
while cues outside luxury goods stores
might be encouraging for the economy
2021 will still be tough many places are
only expecting a third of the tourists
they would have seen pre-pandemic
but at least it's something but when you
choose
to be a waiter when you choose to have a
pizzeria
or when you choose to offer the best of
the french luxury clothing
it's it's the job you decided to do and
what drives you
to go at work every morning and this was
forbidden for us
for nearly one year it was very tough
we're not out of it yet president
emmanuel macron said as he took coffee
with his prime minister john castex
but the government hopes a newly
accelerated vaccination program
will mean there'll be no more lockdowns
now the french government
is taking a gamble more than thirteen
thousand people a day are still testing
positive
for covid19 compare that with the uk in
a similar population
and there two and a half thousand people
a day are testing positive
and the uk only started reopening a few
weeks ago
bernard smith al jazeera paris